et 2019 risque d'être la deuxième ou
troisième année la plus chaude depuis le
début des relevés de température en 1850
c'est là un des arguments utilisés par
des experts environnementaux pour
convaincre les dirigeants mondiaux de
l'urgence climatique décideurs
chercheurs militants sont réunis à
madrid depuis hier dans le cadre de la
conférence internationale sur le climat
la coop 25
maintenant comment décarboniser nos
activités tout en stimulant l'économie
c'est le défi qui se pose à nous alors
de 2020 on en parle avec pierre olivier
pineau de hec montréal bonsoir vous
publié aujourd'hui la chaire de gestion
du secteur de l'énergie de hec et
transition énergétique québec publie un
rapport production productivité
énergétique amorcé la décarbonisation en
stimulant l'économie
qu'est ce que vous voulez démontrer
est-ce qu'on veut démontrer puis on sait
il faut réduire notre consommation
d'énergie et les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et on pense souvent que
c'est au détriment de l'économie que ça
va affecter l'économie
or on peut faire les deux en même temps
stimuler l'économie et réduire notre
consommation d'énergie et les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre c'est ce qu'on
veut montrer à travers ce concept de
productivité énergétique
particulièrement au canada
pourquoi parce que le canada est un très
mauvais élève de la productivité
énergétique donc la productivité
énergétique définie sais ce que c'est
exactement alors c'est la quantité de
richesse de valeur ajoutée que on arrive
à produire avec une unité de
consommation d'énergie et donc dans
différents pays avec la même unité
d'énergie on va produire plus ou moins
de richesse et au canada on est des
cancres de cette productivité
énergétique
on a tiré quelques uns des graphiques
qui sont dans l'étude que vous avez
présenté aujourd'hui
allons-y tout de suite sur la
productivité énergétique du secteur des
services vous avez là tous les pays de
l' ocde en 2016 et on voit clairement
que la productivité canadienne est très
faible
la plus faible absolument tous les pays
font mieux ça veut dire qu'ils arrivent
avec la même unité d'énergie à produire
plus de services pour les biens c'est la
même chose on a on a fait l'analyse
exhaustive là les différents secteurs de
l'économie et pour tous les secteurs de
l'économie
heureusement on fait le constat que le
canada produit moins de richesses moins
de valeur ajoutée pour chaque unité
d'énergie et ça peut passer du de 900 $
au canada à des 2000 dollars pour des
pays européens
et ça montre un petit peu le fait qu on
a des retards dans notre efficacité
énergétique et quand on parle d'unité
d'énergie toutes formes d'énergie alors
ici oui cesser toute forme d'énergie
confondues l'unité c'est le gigajoule
met donc ça combine à la fois le gaz
naturel l'électricité les produits
pétroliers qui sont consommés évidemment
tous et toutes ces gigajoule d'énergie
ne sont pas autant et maîtrise l'une que
l'autre
parce que au québec l'électricité par
exemple n'émet pas de gaz à effet de
serre par contre il faut qu'on soit
efficace dans tous les secteurs parce
que on veut électrifier il faut libérer
de l'électricité pour aller répondre à
certains besoins de certaines industries
qui elles doivent réduire leurs
combustibles fossiles donc on voit bien
que dans ce graphique là dans ce tableau
là que le canada est à 917 dollars de
valeur ajoutée par unité d'énergie
produit ça c'est pour le secteur des
'services' on admire secteur
manufacturier s'est très faible
également deuxième tableau la
productivité énergétique maintenant en
fonction du prix en industriel de
l'électricité voilà alors une
explication à ce qu'on se pose la
question pourquoi est ce qu'on a une si
faible productivité énergétique et la
réponse elle n'est pas unie
dimensionnelle mais elle réside
grandement dans l'abondance d'énergie à
bas prix que l'on trouve
particulièrement au canada et au québec
on a beaucoup d'hydroélectricité
beaucoup de gaz naturel beaucoup de
pétrole et quand on se compare aux pays
de s'aider eux on paye très peu cher et
là on le voit les pays qu'en plus ils
payent leur énergie chère et donc on si
on se promène du gauche vers la droite
en paie le prix des criées de
d'électricité mais d autres sources
d'énergie de plus en plus cher et bien
on voit la prod la tendance à une
augmentation de la productivité avec le
professeur on paie pas cher on n'est pas
très productif on n'est pas productif
par contre on garde le royaume-uni
l'espagne le portugal
ils vont à payer beaucoup plus cher leur
rhji et vont avoir une productivité plus
grande en quelque sorte et il est en
train de nous dire qu'il faut payer plus
cher pour nous notre énergie et notre
électricité mais alors évidemment le
premier réflexe est non mais sauf que
quand on paye plus cher on est plus
ingénieux et on extrait on trouve des
manières de faire plus avec la même
quantité d'énergie parce que justement
on veut pas ou consommer autant
d'énergie mais quand même la suède la
norvège
ici il paie trop cher pour leur
électricité mais leur niveau de
productivité élevé absolument c'est ne
pas l'unique indicateur le prix n'est
pas la seule chose mais c'est un inquiet
d'un indicateur important est évidemment
il ya d'autre attitude parce que le avec
le prix on a la culture une culture
d'efficacité énergétique une culture de
gaspillage jusqu'à un peu jusqu'à un
certain point
et selon les contextes il ya d'autres
variables qui explique des différences
alors on voit bien que le canada est
très faible sur cette question là
maintenant quand on regarde les
provinces canadiennes
il y a des provinces qui font mieux que
d'autres et des provinces qui sont en
difficulté que ça va paraître
incessamment donc le québec par exemple
est plus beau que l'ontario oui alors on
est au québec mieux que la moyenne
canadienne qu'on voit ici on est à 2 103
dollars de richesse générée par unité
d'énergie on est mieux que le canada
mais on est moins que l'ontario les 14 %
moins productifs par une énergie que
l'ontario que 203 l'ontario est un peu
plus de 136 la moyenne canadienne et la
moyenne canadienne et bassel s'est
grandement expliqué par le fait que
l'alberta la saskatchewan sondés et des
provinces extrêmement énergivore et sont
elles très peu productive at on besoin
d'énormément d'énergie pour générer 1
dollars de richesse l'usiné papier
masson est un bon exemple d'utilisation
maximal de bonne productivité
énergétique
donc c'est un des quatre cas que nous
avons étudiés dans ce rapport qu'on
lance aujourd'hui pour montrer que c'est
justement possible parce qu'on voulait
montrer que c'est au delà du concept au
québec c'est possible il ya des
entreprises qu'ils font de réduire leur
consommation d'énergie et des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre en augmentant
leur production donc en créant plus de
valeur ajoutée ils augmentent leur
production ils en vendent plus mais ils
consomment moins d'énergie et la papier
masson
quand on regarde les chiffres les
efforts justement d'efficacité
énergétique qu'ils ont fait à l'inter
avec un suivi rigoureux et bien on
montre qu' il arrive justement à faire
ce découplage de la croissance
économique et de la consommation
d'énergie ce qui est ce qu'on vise à
augmenter la production à l'économie la
richesse collective et diminuer notre
empreinte environnementale
le rapport bien sûr sur le site de la
chaire de gestion du secteur de
l'énergie merci beaucoup pierre olivier
pineau
ça m'a fait plaisir intéressant